Host Acquired.
Listen to me, you got the wrong guy I'm a nobody.
this is going to be fun
The Scarab it chose you Jaime it's
trying to become one with you
how'd you do that wasn't me it was just the suit
It's like Batman stuff, Batman's a fascist
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie there's a
brand new Blue Beetle trailer with a bunch of
new footage so we'll break it all down we get
a good look at one of the villains car packs in
the movie too so I'll explain who that is and what
his relation to the Blue Beetle characters because
he's actually been a villain to all the versions
of the Blue Beetle and the comics if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing a giveaway for tickets to
The Flash movie all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and just post all your predictions
for a Blue Beetle in the comments the connection
between the Blue Beetle movie and what's happening
in The Flash movie is they're using Flashpoint
to sort of soft reboot the DC movies into James
Gunn's DC chapter one with like all the new
connected movies now Matt Reeves will still
be doing his versions of the Batman movie with
Robert Pattinson and all those spin-offs like
the HBO Batman series that we're going to get next
year with the penguin but all that stuff's gonna
be else world's most of the new stuff is going
to be connected starting with Superman Legacy so
I'm not expecting them to reference Blue Beetle
or anything during Superman Legacy but the idea
is James Gunn said that the Blue Beetle movie
could also be part of that new DC chapter 1
because of the way they designed the Blue Beetle
movie the way they filmed it and the story to be
relatively self-contained like it's taking place
in Palmyra city which is a reference to Ray Palmer
or the atom in the comics and even though George
Lopez who plays his uncle during the movie has
that funny Batman joke when they're in Ted cord's
Lab at the end of the trailer they don't say which
version of Batman it is so I think the ideas are
kind of ambiguous about that so I think the idea
is that James Gunn is saying that that could be
the new version of Batman that he's going to cast
for Batman brave in the Bold so the idea is that
it's just a little bit easier for these new Blue
Beetle characters to transition to the new DC
Universe as opposed to the movies from before
this that are super connected to everything that
came before that being said though whether or not
Blue Beetle gets a sequel we'll see that just
depends on how much money it winds up earning
originally they designed the movie to be just for
HBO Max it was relatively smaller but they liked
it so much like it turned out so well while they
were working on it that they actually expanded
they added more to the budget and turned into a
big theatrical movie so we kind of went in the
opposite direction of the Batgirl movie like the
Batgirl movie was meant to feel kind of like a
CW type of movie like a smaller movie Just for
HBO Max for streaming and the people at Warner
Brothers said that they didn't think that it
was good enough for a theatrical release so
Blue Beetle is kind of like the opposite of that
like oh this small little thing that we weren't
gonna pay too much attention to actually turned
out so good that we want everybody to see this we
think it can make a lot of money but it's still
meant to be a much smaller movie in scope than
say like The Flash movie which is kind of like a
mini Justice League movie like they specifically
referenced the Justice League characters and there
are a lot of the Justice League characters in The
Flash movie but one of the other big things they
do in this new footage is they introduce Becky G
as the voice of the Scarab named kajida and it's
literally the Scarab itself like the Scarab isn't
just a technological device it isn't just
like an Iron Man AI like Jarvis or Friday
they're meant to be living techno organic systems
that are genetically engineered by the reach in
a different space sector so the idea is that the
scarabs all have Wills of their own and she could
communicate with the other scarabs and they can
do whatever they want if they're not overridden
if their personalities aren't overridden by
the reach because the reach do designed them
specifically for that if you're a big Star Trek
fan it's kind of like Deep Space Nine with the
vorta and the gem Hadar like they're genetically
engineered basically by the changelings in the
Dominion to do whatever they want them to do but
they do have Wills of their own and they can't
override those instructions if they're strong
enough which is kind of what happens with blue
beetles Scarab many many thousands of years
ago the reach created the scarabs specifically
because of their war with the Green Lantern Corps
or like the earlier version of the Green Lantern
Corps like way before present day previously they
were very warlike culture trying to expand their
territory in the universe in the Green Lantern
Corps stopped them made this treaty and as part
of that treaty they use the scarabs as a backdoor
way to continue expanding their territory but
instead of having to do it the old way like you
see Dark Side during the Justice League Snyder cut
and we will stop at nothing
to possess it ready the Armada
we will use the old ways during that movie
he literally says that they're going to come
conquer the Earth the old way like he's going
to return with a giant Fleet again of course
James Gunn is rebooting the universe so we might
never actually see them pay that off Zack Snyder
said that he didn't want to reveal too much about
that because they might actually wind up doing the
rest of that story but I think he's talking more
about like a comic book or something like that
I've already done a bunch of videos about all the
deleted scenes that he's revealed for his Justice
League Trilogy like Justice League 2 Justice
League three so I'll post a link for that in
the comments below but the idea is that the reach
have had a lot of problems with the Green Lantern
Corps in the past so I think heading into the
future because they have this HBO Green Lantern
series that they're making which is kind of like
True Detective with Hal Jordan and Jon Stewart
they'd probably be the characters that would
connect with Blue Beetle in the future in this
connected Universe the other big coincidence too
is that because Spider-Man into the spider-verse
just came out in theaters even though that's
a Marvel movie like a Sony Marvel Spider-Man
movie Becky G is a musician she also did part of
the soundtrack for spider-verse what the reach
do is they genetically engineer these scarabs
and then before a civilization hits a certain
technological Milestone they'll send a Scarab that
will eventually take over a host and overwrite
that host personality use the power of the Scarab
to take over that planet for the reach and while
that's happening the reach will basically move
like this giant World Ripper above the planet
and eventually mine its resources once the Scarab
takes over the planet so the back story here is
that the reach sent this Scarab to Earth about a
thousand years ago and the reason why it hasn't
activated for the previous versions of Blue Beetle
like Ted cord or Dan Garrett like you see there
are suits in Ted cord's lab here the reason why
they were never able to use the true power of the
Scarab or unlock the Scarab is because the Earth's
civilization just hadn't reached a particular
technological Milestone until the present day of
Jaime Reyes what winds up happening though is that
this Scarab winds up being damaged which is why
the reach aren't able to control it the way they
control the scarabs normally which allows Jaime
Reyes in the Scarab here to do what they want
to do like override the reaches instructions and
be superheroes and try to stop them so the idea
is that this is sort of like a rogue Scarab not
doing what the reach tells it to do they got into
this plot during the Young Justice series Pretty
deeply like the reach shop and become big villains
during one of the seasons even though Darkseid
is always like the much bigger villain behind
everything Blue Beetle is able to fight the other
scarabs because the way that his Scarab works and
is able to communicate with the other scarabs
and convince them to stop fighting him the reach
themselves are super powerful their technology
is way more advanced than anything on Earth the
only beings that could potentially withstand them
are people like the Justice League like Superman
Wonder Woman cyborg because his technology is
based on apocalyptic and Mother Box technology
which is more advanced than the reaches technology
people like the flash Green Lantern even though he
didn't see Green Lantern on the Justice League
yet during the original movies so I think the
idea is that even if they don't do Blue Beetle
too like if they don't do a direct sequel to
this movie they'll have him fight with the other
future Justice League characters the other new
scenes are of him getting ready to fight one of
the other main villains in the movie Conrad car
packs in his suit who during the movie seems like
he's working for Victoria cord in cord Industries
like their finger puppet Victoria cord is meant
to be the True Villain of the movie even though
the reach themselves would technically be the
main villain of the movie I don't think they're
as big during this movie Victoria cord herself
is meant to be the actual main villain just for
this particular movie but in the comics car pack
started out as a normal human who was a villain to
the original Blue Beetle way back in the day Dan
Garrett during his many fights against Dan Garrett
he discovered a secret lab belonging to Ted cord's
Uncle more connections to the second version of
Blue Beetle the lab contained an indestructible
suit of armor that you see in the trailer here he
couldn't get it to work and wound up electrocuting
himself killing himself his mind got transferred
into the robot so he basically became this
Immortal robot with the mind of a human and
because he was Immortal he just eventually lived
on to become a villain to the second version of
Blue Beetle Ted cord and in the movie It seems
like what they're saying is there may have been
a similar type of origin story where he used to
be a human and somehow his mind was transferred
into the robot suit which was built by the modern
cord Industries controlled by Victoria cord and
essentially she is forcing him to go after Blue
Beetle controlling him like a finger puppet the
way the reach are trying to control Blue Beetle
like a finger puppet and they have parallel story
arcs where they both kind of have to override
that and do whatever they want to do so 50 50
on whether or not car packs survived the end of
the movie like whether or not Blue Beetle winds
up killing him in a fight or he decides to turn
good and somehow dies after trying to help Blue
Beetle the way they're fighting here like with
a sword here looks very inspired by Cayman Rider
or Ronin Warriors like very anime inspired Super
Sentai particularly like Japanese series they use
for Power Rangers stuff like that the way they
depict his powers in the trailer the powers of
the suit are pretty accurate that does pretty much
whatever he wants it to do forms whatever he wants
it to form kind of like the way Green Lantern
rings work whatever you can imagine I can create
nice choice maybe if things go well for Blue
Beetle he'll have some minor Crossover with
those Green Lantern characters if you're preparing
for a space Invasion the Green Lantern characters
are the ones that you would want to talk to it
seems like the Jenny character is the one that
leads them into Ted Court's former lab this big
array looks like it might have something to do
with the reach the other scarabs like the whole
idea that there is Invasion coming maybe he'll get
a vision of that through the suits systems like
oh wait a minute what is it that I'm seeing this
is a giant alien race that's coming to kill us
you hear Susan Sarandon's voice as Victoria cord
saying the Scarab chose you but it belongs to me
that's right out of the comics you see her drones
her men working four chord Industries I think
the whole idea is that during the movie Ted Court
isn't around Something's Happened to him he's
disappeared maybe they'll bring him back in some
way but just like in the comics when Jaime Reyes
first debuted when he first became Blue Beetle
Ted Court wasn't around to explain everything him
that didn't happen till later during the New 52
reboot and then eventually the DC rebirth reboot
also there was a couple DC reboots they did bring
the Ted cord character back and he started helping
Jaime Reyes giving him advice and they both were
their versions of Blue Beetle you see them take
off in Ted cord's Classic Blue Beetle ship like
I said he has a lot of Iron Man style technology
he uses his wealth his intellect to make Tech to
become a version of Blue Beetle because the
Scarab doesn't work for him then inside Ted
cord's Lair we see a whole bunch of Easter eggs
in the background there's an Easter egg for Dan
Garrett's Classic Blue Beetle suit Ted cord's
Classic Blue Beetle suit then obviously the
joke from George Lopez's father talking about
Batman Batman is a fascist just because they're
inside Ted core's very batman-like Lair like
Ted core's version of a bat cave because the
movie's coming out in August will start getting
more trailers as we get closer to Comic-Con like
remember Comic-Con is happening at the end of July
so there'll be a bunch of trailers it'll be like
trailer Fest from Marvel and DC and a bunch of
other stuff too I've got a bunch of Flash videos
planned for the next couple of weeks so if you
have any special requests about just DC videos
in general just post them in the comments below
I just posted my review of The Flash movie you
can click here for that and click here for all
my other Flash trailer videos and Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!